bonjour bienvenue dans cette émission
diagonale tv un spécial débutants avec
nino maso a dit maître international
monfourny mouvement et jours alors
aujourd'hui dans cette leçon spécial
débutants en innu on va voir le
déplacement de deux pièces importantes
du jeu d'échecs qui sont le cavalier et
et les pions oui il faut dire par avoir
les autres pieds c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué de placement des cavaliers
parce que vous allez voir ils se
dirigent en pot bizarrement privé et le
pion le déplacement des pièces est assez
facile
par contre il ya les règles particulier
qui suit les pions qui sont différentes
en pot or de comment on va voir le coup
notamment de prises et les promotions
mais ne vous inquiétez pas les échecs
restera accessible à tout le monde bien
sûr c'est quand même c'est pas si
compliqué que ça alors on va voir tout
de suite le déplacement de ce fameux
bourrin le kava l'os lecavalier le
cheval le
le guen voit la plaine nom différent
alors c'est une pièce tout à fait
extraordinaire le cheval alors ici on a
mis deux deux cavaliers on va voir
comment ces cas les bouges alors comment
on peut expliquer le déplacement du
cavallino donc c'est pour les enfants un
pot énorme difficile c'est vos enfants
regard des missions et selon explique
pour faciliter les choses c'est comme
grande et parfois on dit comme ça mais
c'est le voilà peu parfois on est clair
comme ça mais c'est pas forcément d'être
bien expliqué déjà pour donc montrons là
où ça peut aller sept cavaliers donc
alors ce cas elle est poli sur cette
case celle ci celle ci celle ci celle ci
celle ci
celle ci est celle ci alors pourquoi ont
elles ce qu'on voit bien ici regardez la
forme de l ici un petit elle ici voilà
mais c'est un peu trompeur de parler de
l parce que le cavaly saute par dessus
des pièces oui donc parfois vous pouvez
croire
si vous n'avez pas été signé entre
guillemets et ça marche pas non
finalement il faut quand même retenir
les cases final de destination
voilà mais si vous voulez pour pas
placer le cavalier n'importe où et vous
rappelle et c'est à peu près là bas en
trois cases donc penser à alp d'être
fort lors il ya une autre façon de le
dire lors chacun a son truc moi j'ai
trouvé une façon
intéressante de le signaler le cavaly va
toujours sur la case les couleurs
opposées à sa classe de départ est à 2
càs de distance regardez c'est le
meilleure façon de retenir
voilà il ya deux cases ici de distance
et alors on va sur toutes les cases
blanches puisqu'il est sur une case
noire toutes les cases blanches qui sont
à 2 càs de distance inversement
inversement le cavalier sur le blanc il
est sur une case blanche ici il va aller
donc sur les cases p 6 et c'est cette
rade et c'est bien à deux cases et on se
tape par dessus alors a noté howard et
que celui ci il peut aller sur huit
cases à la fois alors que celui là comme
il est au bord mais évidemment il n'y a
pas eu manque d'éclat sur les côtés oui
pourrait aller mieux n'a pas donc il
peut aller qu'il a beaucoup moins de 15
à sa disposition déjà on vous rappelle
on n'est pas au niveau stratégique que
cette fois on juge s'apprendre déplacer
les pièces mais sachez qu'elle est
vraiment très bien toujours placer
l'école et dans le centre parce que
comme stéphane viens de vous dire qu'à
olic et oquendo casse donc il est très
limité alors qu'à l'est dans le centre
et l'a8 casse mais c'est vraiment gênant
pour toutes les pièces
oui mais surtout cavaliers surtout
cavani vraiment placez le dans le centre
voilà et que les cassandre a d'ailleurs
on rappelle ça s'appelle les quatre
casques qui sont au mieux payées dont on
peut montrer parce que oui ces quatre
cases la voilà voilà je vais montre
aussi ont joué ici ça c'est donc ce qu'à
cliquer sur une case centrale il est
beaucoup plus récent voilà voilà donc on
voit les en psychose
on va aller simple oui par exemple
maintenant si vous arrivez à distinguer
comment ça marche déjà où quand comment
le cavalier peut capturer le travail est
par exemple parce que dans les autres
cours que vous avez vraiment on nous
conseille voir nous coûte précédent pour
comprendre entièrement le jeu on va vous
expliquer les captures comment ça marche
et donc par exemple ici comment on peut
capturer le cavalier noir stéphanie
alors comment on peut que nous admettons
qu'on se déplacer que les noirs ne
déplace que le roi 1 que ce soit que les
blancs qui joue donc concentrés ici sur
cette case là ou sur celle là ce ne peut
paraît d'ailleurs celle là ici donc les
noirs par exemple ne toucherait pas
leurs cavaliers pour comment te faut que
les noirs jouent quand même un coup donc
ils joueraient le roi ici on déplace le
cavalier ensuite sur cette case là à
regarder on n'est plus qu'à une seule
case a fait un seul saut ducal du canada
donc si les noirs jouer encore le roi
ici il suffirait de prendre maintenant
le cavalier adverse voilà donc en alors
un autre une en un autre chemin possible
donc là on a fait 1 2 3 et ce sera
toujours 3 mais on va trouver un autre
chemin
ces deux plats c'est par ici et noir
jour et le roi pareil on viendrait sur
cette case menouar jour il en droit et
on prendrait on a remarqué juste rappel
qu'ait aux échecs ses actionnaires joue
à son tour
donc c'est pour ça on dit parfois à
chaque fois qu'ils ont déplacé une pièce
maintenant c'est à l'adversaire de
blessés ces pièces donc elia chacun de
sa tour voilà donc en fait si ça se
passait vraiment dans une partie en fait
un prix offert du coup cavaliers là on
joue le roi ainsi les blancs mettez leur
cavalier ici les noirs maintenant en
train de jouer pour eux-mêmes prendre le
cavalier donc ça serait pas une bonne
idée
donc attention où vous juste ici pour
l'instant les possibilités mais voilà au
monde les possibilités mais c'est pas
forcément ce qu'il faut c'est pas
forcément les bons coups mais c'est pour
voir comment on bouge comme en bouche le
cavalier comment on aurait pu
effectivement prendre la pièce à des
sens vous pourrez jamais faire du coup
la suite aux échecs c'est pour ça qu'il
faut arriver donc sur ces 7
c'est l'adversaire aussi peu voilà alors
on va montrer aussi que les lecavalier
en fait non
ossements c'est pas comme la tour le fou
la dame qui qui sont bloqués dans leur
progression
s'il ya une pièce de leur propre camp
ailleurs ou du camp adverse 6 et du camp
adverse ils peuvent la prendre mais ils
peuvent pas aller au delà
par contre ici on va montrer un exemple
il suffit que si les blancs jouent ici
par exemple et que les noirs jouent
leurs cavaliers sur la case b6
lecavalier là peut toujours venir sur
les cases à cette ou ces sept locales et
là ne fait pas obstacle le calice son
pardessus même s'il y avait d'autres
pièces ici sur ces cases la des pièces
des pions n'importe quoi le gall et
pourrait toujours venir sur cc vous
rappelez des positions de départ des non
courants numéro un a révisé
donc là vous allez voir le kawaï et peut
tout de suite sauté sur les pions tout à
fait dans la position initiale
le cavalier les cavaliers qui ont
regardé fait un petit effort
d'imagination les cavaliers sont placés
ici et même il ya des pions évidemment
sur ses rangées là partout tout à fait
ici et donc les cavaliers peuvent
directement
on n'est pas obligé de jouer les pions
au début on peut très bien revenir sur
la case f3c 3 sur la case à 3 ou alors
pour l'autre cavalier peut très bien
aller sur la case f3 voix est là car
bien sûr ce sera la même chose pour les
noirs et c'est pareil pour les noirs
évidemment donc on va placer maintenant
on va passer par don maintenant
justement déplacement des pions qui vont
nous intéresser et qui est encore plus
techniques les pions le petit lion il
est bourré de ressources en fait on va
voir ça alors ici voilà on a mis deux
pions alors donc hautement se déplace le
pion voilà au début rien de particulier
puisque les pions 7e place tout droit et
c'est très facile à jouer
c'est le seul ps aux échecs qui n'a pas
droit de réguler n'est pas oublier ça
parce que n'importe quelle pièce où
jouer vous allez voir après roy aussi ou
n'importe la tour le fou qu'on a déjà
passé la dame il peut réunir connu mais
pas les pions une fois tout fait il ne
revient jamais donc voilà donc le pion
va tout droit donc en principe le pion
va va une seule case
en principe donc voilà en par an mais il
entre et on va montrer voilà par exemple
vous bouger comme ça les noirs etc
vous allez comprendre le pionner peut
pas aller donc ni sur les rangées nez
sur les diagonales pour enfants
juste droits que tout voilà trop le
choix lions n'ont pas le choix d'aller
autrement que tout droit voyez donc
c'est très facile quand vous voyez
maintenant donc le petit complications
entre nîmes et première exception ne
s'est pas exception d une règle première
donc notice sait qu'il peut aller sur
d'occase exceptionnellement à la départ
donc donc le pion où il peut au départ
sert quand il est encore sur sa case de
départ sert la deuxième rangée pour les
blancs et la septième pour les noirs
n'importe quand dans la partie c'est pas
que le premier coup la partie si le
premier coup du pillon concernés même si
vous dire est plus rien comme case là
c'est le cas d'ailleurs si on peut
imaginer que ça c'est une fin de partie
alors c'est une scène partie les blancs
peuvent jouer leurs pions soit d'une
case évidemment ça c'est le coût normal
ou alors le choix ils ont le choix de
jouer de deux cases
c'est le seul cas le seul moment
cirqu'en le pion est encore sur la
première case il a le choix entre une ou
deux cadres
c'est le seul car après il n'a plus le
choix que de se déplacer que 2 par
exemple et noir jouent lui de une case
et après on peut se déplacer que d'une
case on n'a plus le choix il ya plus
cette possibilité donc sept points des
cats ne veux pas revenir sur des docks
par exemple il dit si si par exemple
vous ne pouvez plus venir pas grave
s'ils ont directement sur des docks on
va venir ici sur des deux parce qu'on
n'est pas sur la photo avec à 30 par an
donc alors que débarque donc en avant
rien d'expliquer où vous pouvez aller
parfois en fait si vous avez un enduit
sur de casse au départ on a le choix
entre une case ou deux au départ du pion
quand le pion est encore sur sa case
initiale il a le choix
donc ces joueurs quels choix maintenant
au passé sur le prise c'est qui est
aussi une règle exceptionnel alors on va
voir me donne la prise du pion mais
alors le pion se déplace comme ça mais
comment il prend alors si on suivait la
règle qu'on a vu pour toutes les pièces
il devrait prendre comme il avance c'est
à dire juste devant lui oui et c'est le
clp est donc déjà qu'on a dit que c'est
le ps qui ne revient pas en arrière
maintenant c'est celle pièce unique
c'est très différent des autres pièces
qui ne prend pas habituellement
vous allez voir alors on nous a expliqué
il s'est dirigé devant mais il prend sur
les diagonales à côté alors ça c'est
vraiment c'est à dire fou si on prend le
cas de son pion ici dit non
oui il a le choix il peut venir
évidemment une case ici ou deux quasi si
loin c'est ça quand vous avez appris une
case ou deux cases ont par exemple
déplacer tout simplement j'aurai ce coup
là on va jouer un coup le roi et jouer
ce coup là où a directement directement
jouer directement de deux cases ici donc
ça c'est ce qu'on vient de voir
oui et on le met par contre il y peut
pas prendre des vents d'ailleurs et
jae-bum mais par exemple et on achète on
va montrer cet exemple si on fait ce
qu'on peut pas prendre les tours par
exemple les blancs jouent le coup de
trois mais on se dit ah super mon pions
ici h7 je vais bouger d'une case je vais
prendre la tour parce que tout à l'heure
on a vu que tous les pièces sur les
routes et croisés il pourrait pas de
capturer ces pièces adversaire s'il en
fait non mellano on peut pas il est
bloqué il est bloqué ici le plan du
chayla pas le droit de prendre la tour
alors moment les pions prennent les
pions donc froid sur les diagonales à
les pions prennent sur les diagonales
donc voilà option ils vont prendre donc
les pions ici peut prendre mais sur une
case une seule case n'imaginais pas que
vous allez confus pour prendre quelque
chose dans la loire valley que d'une
seule case donc on peut prendre soin le
plus 9,3 soit s'ils avaient une pièce
ici mais on n'a pas si vous avez une ps
juste à côté
voilà on peut prendre l'adversaire alors
si on passe sa propre pièce ont indiqué
les captures pas ses propres pièces donc
que vous pouvez prendre là par exemple
autre exemple quand on reprend 2,3 et
voilà voilà
on apprend qu'on a retiré cette pièce
d'une l'échiquier on a pris sa place
comme tout à l'heure pour les autres
pièces donc ce sera la même chose donc
imaginé pour ces cinq donc sept pions
comme un élu à prendre il reprend aussi
donc vous soit vous prenez à gauche ou à
droite ça peu importe il suffit que vous
avez une pièce in pieces sur la petite
diagonale juste à côté du pion mais par
contre là ici ce pion ici ne peut pas
prendre la tour puisque la tour et juste
devant foca est la tour c'est par
exemple si les tours je joue mais
d'insurgés 6 si l'aca russie ce qui
serait une faute
là il peut prendre voilà alors il ya le
choix le pion on n'est pas obligé de
prendre aux échecs évidemment oui mais
on n'est pas obligé à prendre et et on
s'abstient pu bouger en h 7 h 6 pardon
ou alors en h5 on aurait très bien pu
jouer ce coup évidemment faire
l'occurrence si on nous offre une tour
gratuite
on va peut-être la prendre
voilà donc ça on a vu l'a donc là c'est
pas pareil un petit rappel une fois
cette paix en surgissent ici lé peuple
ou aller sur d'occase par exemple parce
qu'il est déjà bougé déjà on voit balle
et surtout g4 on recollerait mais si on
referait 5g quatre ans par an on ne peut
pas venir ici il y avait aussi regretté
mon nom dont quelques beaucoup pour
arriver jusqu'ici
voilà donc il faut venir ici après on
pourra bouger on n'a rien à apprendre
ici à rien apprendre ici non plus donc
la 6e joueuse 4 par contre et on s'est
croisés ici on joue f4 si des noirs
maintenant joue le coup gsm et bien on
peut prendre
voilà ou alors on peut avancer on n'est
pas obligé de prendre on peut choisir et
notamment prendre le pion fils inc on
espère vous allez compris ça on va
passer à la promotion alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ça la promotion chrono
derrière on a vu alors le pion c'est
quand même compliqué parce qu'alors dont
le cavalier déjà c'est pas simple
puisque on a vu qu'il a un déplacement
bon on a compris et xavier legaz plus
loin il saute par dessus et il atterrit
sur une case de couleurs opposées
bon le pion on a vu que le pion 1 quand
il ya encore sur sa première case il
peut choisir de bouger devant lui d'une
ou de deux cases
s'il a une pièce devant lui il est
coincé quand il prend il prend sur sa
diagonale
alors non seulement déjà c'est compliqué
mais alors en plus maintenant il ya une
nouveauté alors tout à fait
extraordinaire avec le pion ses reprises
un passant de déjà c'est la prison alors
oui c'est à leiria il ya deux prises il
ya deux nouveautés extraordinaire qu'on
va voir ici il ya un la prise en passant
alors qui est quelque chose de tout à
fait fantastique
oui vous allez voir c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel aussi on encore plus
exceptionnel et la promotion
voilà l'oncle option c'est peut-être une
pièce qui va pas loin qui est un peu
mais d'abord un c'est une pièce qui est
en surnombre puisqu'il y en a 8 sur les
chenilles est beaucoup plus que les
autres pièces et en plus vous avez vu
toutes les règles qui sont sur le pion
pour cette petite pièce qui ont fait
quelque chose de tout à fait magique
alors ici dans cette position on va voir
s'il en est simple passade donc alors si
c'est aux blancs de jouer imaginons que
les blancs jouent le coup c4 alors on
peut jouer ce coup puisque le pion était
encore sur la première case on a le
choix ici entre jouer le pion sur ces
trois sur ces 3 ou sur ces 4 on n'a pas
d'autre choix puisqu'il n'y a pas de
pièces en b3 ya pas de pièces en d3 donc
on n'a rien à apprendre
donc si on joue ces 4 si on joue alors
déjà on va le dire si on joue le
ou c3 évidemment commenté lynn est donc
ici voilà au choix aux alternatifs noir
dont peuvent jouer sans par exemple le
coup ici soit le couperet évident pour
jouer le pion aux tirs mais en
l'occurrence ici on peut choisir de
prendre le pion bon donc les blancs se
disent super bon j'ai vu qu'il peut me
prendre
si je joue le pion en c3 donc afin
d'échapper à cette prise je vais jouer
mon pion de deux cases mais là et là l
oreille aux prises alors ça s'appelle la
prise en bassin est assez extraordinaire
et donc on vous montrait tout de suite
qu'est ce que ça veut dire youpi on paie
comme capturer ses pions blancs qui a
loire le droit des captures et le pur
noir peut prendre regarder dans le vide
ils disent ils comme si le pion n'avait
bougé que d'une case voyez c'est pour ça
je vous montrer que si on joue ces trois
et noir peuvent prendre et si on joue
ses cartes est belle et douce à la
mémoire haute a quand même regarder ils
prennent en passant regarder le futur
disparu regardez comme c'est énorme on
joue le piote de 15 et le noie le
tournoi reprend dans le vide et fait
disparaître le pur alors justement va
expliquer quand même cette règle qui est
quand même extraordinaire
justement au départ historiquement les
pions ne pouvait pas jouer de deux cases
mais on voyait que les parties étaient
un peu lente et c'est donc pour
accélérer le jeu on a dit bon au premier
coup d'un pion il peut jouer et de
quatre oui mais alors y'a des joueurs
après qu'ils ont fait leur beurre oui
mais attendez parce qu'avant quand
j'avais un pion ici jean péché manquions
d'avancé et maintenant avec votre
nouvelle règle je peux plus et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a inventé la règle
en passant si alors la règle est la
suivante elle faut être précis quand
même si le pion adverse joue de deux
cases et qu'on a un pion donc placé ici
soit à droite soit à gauche sur la case
ici et b4 ou des cas c'est vrai
évidemment pour tous les pions et bien
le coup d'après uniquement le coup
d'après uniquement c'est pas valable un
coup de coude trois coups plus tard le
coup d'après uniquement uniquement dans
le cas où le pion adverse a bougé de
deux cases
oui le coup d'après uniquement le pion
peut prendre le pion adverse ici comme
s'ils avaient bougé que d'une seule case
c'est ça la règle en fait vous pourrez
marquer très facilement quand même pour
faire prise en passant si vous êtes avec
le noir il faut absolument être comme
vous ou vos votes pillon soit sur
quatrième rangée parce que c'est le sel
en dhr
4e rangée où l'adversaire va bouger son
cul sur d'occase parce que peut-être
case départ tk ce départ comme l'endroit
où le pion la 3d bouger sur dos cassé le
case de départ c'est-à-dire deuxième
rangée
donc ça s'est jamais passé si le puits
on était sur une autre place que
quatrième rangée qu'on va montrer 4ème
rang j'ai donc c'est catherine hamon
flèche
voilà ça c'est catherine granger par
contre avec les blancs cet exemple peut
être uniquement dans les cas si vous
êtes sûr 5e branger parce qu'elle les
pièces adversaires il doit se déplacer
suscinio déplacer sur d'occase des
pièces d'été case départ voilà donc on
va revoir on va revoir l'astuce
imaginons que les blancs jouent de deux
cases alors on a le choix on n'est pas
obligé de prendre donc imaginons que ce
soit les noirs aux mêmes qui jouent
leurs pions ce pion g7 toujours sur la
case lie paris le joug de deux cases et
les blancs peuvent choisir d'abord de
jouer le roi de jouer ce pion là mais
aussi et pompes de pousser le pion ou
alors de prendre en passant donc la
prise en passant regardez c'est
fantastique
hop je prends comme si le bouillon noire
n'avait bougé que d'une case uniquement
le coup d'après si vous jouez un autre
coup vous n'avez plus le droit de faire
cette prise évidemment c'est que le coup
d'après vous avez ce choix
hop et le pion disparaissent et c'est
que oui on a encore rappelé répéter donc
il faut prendre tout de suite si vous
avez une prendre après vous a plu trois
là par exemple
bien sûr des 4 s'il ne prend pas tout de
suite ou sur g5 à n'importe quel que là
par exemple si les noirs ne prend pas
sur ces trois tout de suite après c'est
fini là ils n'auront plus droit de
toucher en octobre ça il faut explique
donc donc se remontre ici donc c'est 4
donc très simple et on appelle ça le
pion f prend la case justice et le pion
ici aussi remarqué ça veut passer avec
n'importe quel point un homme sur
n'importe quel colonnes et soit à gauche
ou à droite
alors maintenant ce qu'on va voir c'est
que et bien ses pions sont tout proches
pression faire la promotion alors
imaginons que les deux noirs maintenant
joue le coup par exemple de roi ici on
pousse le pion ici donc on explique
c'est quoi le promotion donc
ce que c'est la promo de promotion c'est
que je faisais magique il peut dire et
là on regardait les revoilà donc c'est
l'heure le pion ici est proche de
fernand oui qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on arrive au dernier rang j'ai donc si
vous savez les blancs ou vous arrive au
8e rang j'ai donc et avec le noir par
exemple au premier rang j'ai alors
regardé ce que propose mon petit
logiciel ici quand je suis arrivé au
bout ici il me dit qu'est ce que je veux
une dame ou une tour ou un fou ou un
cavalier pas forcément une dame d'un
bloc notes en général on fait notre
petit bureau où elle s'est transformée
par avoir votre foi dans une pièce le
plus simple qu'il était avant donc c'est
une sorte de récompense pour avoir le
courage à reus cas dernièrement j'ai
alors on a le choix on n'est pas obligé
de faire dame c'est à dire que ici je
peux très bien choisir de faire cavalier
ça peut arriver à des cas particuliers
on va préférer faire un cavalier pour
des raisons techniques
on va vous dire non à peu près 99% je
pense qu'on va faire plus tôt là dedans
parce que c'est une pièce très fruits
sentent comme on a vu c'est la
combinaison des torts et faux dans notre
autre cours et si dans un cas
particulier comme c'est fait on vient de
dire donc on peut choisir soit le fou
soit le cavalier soit la tour attention
on peut pas dire moi je ne veux rien
déjà mon ce sera bizarre réfusé de cette
possibilité de d'avoir fait ça une pièce
puissante mais vous pouvez pas juste
laissé un pion s'attendent enfin on peut
penser ou en répétant voilà parce qu'il
ya seulement vous pouvez jamais faire
roues abs que dans un jeu où il
n'existait pas avoir droit
alors que vous pouvez avoir donc
finalement voir dos d'âne trier 3
d'armes quatre cavaliers si vous faites
quatre promotions pour faire tant que
vous voulez si vous avez vu c'est à dire
me ranger on a huit pions on a deux
cavaliers déjà au départ donc si on peut
faire éventuellement on peut trouver une
partie où on peut faire en tout on
pourrait avoir dix cavaliers
oui ces défis si on arrivait passé oui
si on arrivait de ramasser dont capturer
tous les pions d'adversaire pour libérer
les cascades surtout après il faut faire
vite fois progression
ça sera très fort mais ça n'existait pas
ou ne rêve pas loupé le drop dans la
pratique
dans la pratique on peut faire un ou
revoir jusqu'à douze propositions mais
pas plus que ça wen en général que les
pille on s'échange aussi au début aussi
voilà alors on va voir un autre exemple
ici non non je crois qu'il y avait un
autre
je veux juste passer rapidement
voilà ici
si oui ou non ce que je voulais montrer
c'est que si les blancs jouent ici
oui et non je crois qu'il y avait
quelque chose à montrer c'est que si
quand on arrive au bout une ancienne
pièce on n'a pas le cas ici mais si on a
une pièce ici évidemment on peut choisir
de faire dame en prenant la pièce ou
alors en avançant que ça ne vous
interdit pas de faire promotion soit pas
reprise va vraiment c'est quand vous
avez expliqué il peut prendre la main
sur l'imaginaire qui est une tour ici
adverse et bien évidemment on pourrait
la prendre en même temps et ça ferait
quand même promotion on pourrait changer
donc ça vous empêche pas par contre s'il
ya une pièce donc justement placé on
indiqué ça peut bloquer voilà et bien
donc arrêtée mais avec les pions comme
c'est une pièce exceptionnelle donc qui
ne prend pas sur sa route
normand pour arrêter l'agression des
pions s'ils nous attaquent
il suffit de placer quelque chose une
pièce t27 pions et ça va s'arrêter
il faut pas placer par contre juste à
côté sur le diagonal pour qui le
carburant bien sûr donc ce pion est tout
à fait extraordinaire il peut bouger
donc de deux cases au début ou lors
d'une case de façon générale devant lui
il prend sur les côtés il peut être pris
en passant quand ils jouent sont deux
cas et s'il ya un clan adverse sur la
quatrième rangée pour les blancs sur la
5eme ranger pour les noirs et donc quand
ils arrivent au bout il se transforme en
plus à une pièce qui peut être beaucoup
plus puissants dont les pions sont très
très importants aux échecs et il peut
paraît que les arrêts derrière et là par
exemple sur qui sur cette île peut
jamais faire on sera alors interdit de
reculer si on a oublié de dire mon
fiancé ubs qui n'a pas droit de réguler
c'est la seule pièce c'est la seule
pièce toutes les autres pièces le peut
la seule pièce qui effectivement ne peut
pas reculer aux échecs le pion voilà
donc vous avez vu les deux pièces
peut-être les plus difficiles à cerner
aux échecs qui sont le pion et les pions
et les cavaliers qui sont sans doute
effectivement les pièges depuis
difficile à appréhender beaucoup plus
que tour fouet dame qui qui sont
relativement simples à comprendre mais
le prochain coup vous aider d'assimiler
les rares mouvements et vous allez voir
ça va aller plus facilement
voilà donc c'est terminé pour cette
leçon sur les cavaliers et les pions
voilà et je vous dis à bientôt pour une
autre émission merci ni non fondées rien
horreur